good morning everyone welcome along to
this extraordinary meeting of the
performance policy and partnerships
committee uh i'll declare the meeting
open and welcome those who are joining
us on our live stream
uh attending on zoom we have councillors
uh councillor abbott
mrs coote reverend cook rhiannon
i have an apology from councillor
pottinger
no others that i'm aware of i'll move
that
consequ
if there are any declarations of
interest remember that they can be
made at the time the item comes up next
step for the city block uh and city
streets deliberations
um welcome along alex
we're only just starting
um rhiannon would you like to introduce
the paper for us please
uh um councillors i'm sorry hayden
powell who's our policy advisor he's
going to run you through the um
submissions and what we heard from the
public
thanks welcome hayden
thanks mr chair
morning councillors
uh this consultation follows on from
previous consultations in 2019 and 2020
this consultation asked the public what
their thoughts were on the city block
funding and city centre streets stage
two
closer
uh ppp received the submissions and
heard from submitters on 17 february
2022.
79 submitted
which was less than previous
consultations
this was expected due to the widespread
communications that had gone on with
this and also being the third time that
people had the chance to submit on the
subject
submissions for city blocks showed that
74.7
were in favor of council's preferred
option
eight point nine percent in favor of the
alternative option
and sixteen point five percent either
did not select an option or stated they
were against it
submissions for the city centre streets
upgrade showed
48.1 percent in favor of the council
preferred option
29.1 in favor of the alternative option
with 22.8 either not answering it or not
in support at
all the outcome for the consultation was
clear with a significant majority of
submitters supporting the council
preferred option for the city block
funding
with city center streets submitters
there was support for
further fund upgrades with 48 in favor
of council deferred option and 29
supporting the more expensive option
that was put up as well
uh as you see randon has joined us on
zoom as well we'll have to take any
questions that the counselors may have
thanks hayden
questions counselors you had a chance to
uh read through the submissions prior to
last week you had a chance to hear a a
few submitters just bearing in mind that
the
uh during the submissions there were
some points that were made they were off
topic um we note those but they're not
really forming part of the decisions
that we're making this morning
uh minutes can also note that
councillors lush and kit have joined the
meeting any questions for hayden
councillor clark no question for michael
moore
in the paper talks about
the option costing 13.6 million dollars
as an increased cost
so just a statement on that and then a
question
that seems an awfully big
overspend on what we initially forecast
for this project
but secondly and quite rightly you you
forecast for us that would impact on a
1.3 increase
so my question is around are there other
alternatives as opposed to potentially
pushing up rates
because that 1.3 is significant because
it's not just 1.3 next year it goes into
the base rate
um
that households provide and it compounds
so next year won't be 1.3 it'll be 1.4
1.5 1.6 whatever the impact is so that
keeps escalating upwards if you build it
in as opposed to somehow
funding it with with other sources
so i'd like your view on that and and
secondly i'd like to know um
what other options we've got in front of
us as opposed to a a rate increase
mr day
through yourself the chair um
all funding options were reviewed as as
part of the process
when it comes down to
funding projects of this nature sadly
borrowing is the
only way
and the rates impact that you are
looking at is in relation to the
repayment of that borrowing it's it's
not a one-off payment to
secure those funds it is actually a
rating repayment from that perspective
uh borrowing repayment from that
perspective
yeah
supplementary question of that i
appreciate that and and
and borrowing's probably the way to go
but
um borrowing and paying back what you
borrow
is not just on this one project it's a
much wider picture than that as we all
know
and so one of the issues for me is
what's happened to the
funds that were made available by the
sale of the farm
with that was that um that money um used
to reduce debt
and if it was and we are subsequently
pushing some more borrowing into that
debt area
surely it must be fiscally neutral if
we're looking to um
to increase our debt loading by 13.6
and let's say foreign or 12 million
dollars for the farm sale and i don't
know what that was but if that was the
case then surely it wouldn't be a 1.3
increase
through self-chair um just just touching
on the topic of the um i believe it's
the aurora farm that we are talking
about that will be coming back at the
next ppp but i confirm there's no and no
additional funds that can be um
used for other ventures of this nature
but also that those ring fence funds
from perspective investment properties
at this stage
council would need to make a resolution
to shift any funds out of investment
properties but having said that
it is coming back and you'll get the net
result in relation to the next ppp
meeting
further questions counselor amundsen
um i have a couple of questions also
first one is around the piazza
and
the increase of 15 million and just
looking at the document that we put out
for consultation it talked about the
piazza
being um
the responsibility of the developer
and looking at an article that appeared
in the newspaper i think uh
when the consultation document came out
it said that the piazza was included in
the scope of the work
so can i just get some clarification
about whether the increase in the budget
is because of the reasons that we've
outlined in the consultation document
which includes the increase in
construction cost bank fees and the cost
of
incentives
or whether it is because we're adding in
something new to the proposal
i'll ask rhiannon to make a quick
comment
um
so through your chat um regarding the um
consultation document those details are
correct with the issues around the
piazza
that
those can
the consultation is around the
additional funding required to make the
connections
to the piazza rather than to fund the
piazza itself which fits within the
wider project it is quite um a complex
area of the project so it's not
surprising perhaps that the article
didn't pick that up completely
accurately
so it is around connections things like
lifts and the connecting the existing
areas of the mall to that piazza
thanks for that clarification
cool
my other questions are around the risks
that have been identified in this
proposal
and i guess my first question about that
is
it says
that there is a short term or a low risk
somewhere um with the bank funding
that it should
come back to us within two years
um what is the plan if that doesn't
happen because i'm very aware that we've
identified lots of risks along the way
in this project and most of them have
actually been realized so far
so i'm wondering what will happen when
this risk is realised
i'll um defer to michael on that
question he's de-masking as we speak
through yourself chair
yes there is a low risk and associated
to that um
we
are monitoring in relation to
rentals
that is the the key figure from our
perspective there's already
enough
rentals actually signed up to
lower the risk to a very low risk from
our perspective and that's why we've
flagged it
the realization
of that is of course always possible
because it is a risk and it will stay as
a risk
should that come to fruition we will
need to look at the finances in year two
to see what we do from a capital
application going forward it does affect
our debt cap
but we do have capacity if council
desired to re-look at that at that time
and i guess following on from that then
is there any risk that the bank will
change the rules again
um given that there are lots of changes
happening in the finance area with you
know inflation and all of those kinds of
things
whose self cheer um i'm i'm not at
liberty to say um what what the bank
wallet won't do um
from our perspective at the moment
they've got a
an agreement with the bank
what the bank does between
buyer and seller at that particular
point
i can't guarantee
my interest in and looking is uh getting
out of it as quick as possible from a
rate player's point of view so we are
looking at it respectively once that two
years up then we want to be out as as
fast as we can
so um i guess following on from that the
further risk that
i can see
is that
many of the tenants that are moving into
the city block are residents at the
moment on the north side of esk street
and we are essentially taking all of
those people and putting them somewhere
else which is leaving a whole block of
street of
shops potentially vacant which i see as
a risk for council especially with the
streetscape work that we're doing
is there anything in the pipeline or is
there anything that we should be doing
at this point in time to help mitigate
that risk because i see that as
you know potentially quite detrimental
to the city especially if our goal is
around that community outcome and
enhancing the entire cbd and is not
purely focused on a shopping mall
i think that actually falls out of the
purvey of what we're trying to do and i
don't actually see it as any different
as say
the anchor tenant
so we might skip past that one
there's there's no way to mitigate that
that type of risk people will move
around from one building to another
anyway and that's part of normal
business i'm not sure
what we could do to mitigate
apart from what we're doing in the
streetscapes to make it an attractive
area
i guess i'm not necessarily looking at
mitigation because it's too late for
that i'm thinking of what are we going
to do to address it
i'll come back to the streetscapes that
we're improving in the area to attract
business i think it's about the only
thing
we could answer with
within what we can do legally council's
not in a position to pay incentives to
people to come and occupy
premise owned by individual landlords
but we're doing it with the city block
exactly we're not doing that that's out
of order
this is hadley sorry mr chair i was just
going to remind all councillors and any
members of the public that this
development is unusual in the resource
consent requirements
that the doors of the mall
that face onto west street must remain
open
and that is a particularly unusual step
in terms of planning and it's one that i
would expect um trudy's team to be
really focused on ensuring that we have
compliance with that at all times
any further questions councillor so i've
got councillor lewis's worship and
council of sopa thank
you the dialogue between mr bay and and
counselor
covered my question thank you your
worship
yeah so the impression i i got from uh
the submissions that were made is that
they want to the job to go ahead
regardless of some of the finer details
and
that
when we had uh
little ticky tours of that it was
suggested again there that
the worst thing that could happen or the
greatest risk is that the project
is is half finished and we we've just
got to get the job done it seemed to be
the attitude i picked up
counselor sopher
thanks mr chair um my questions in
relation to the city centre street
upgrade
and the number of submitters who
unusually
preferred the more expensive option
um and we've made the comment that
perhaps we didn't communicate as well as
we could the reason that council made
the recommendation we did for the other
option um being
that some submitters might not have been
aware that the additional roading space
that the alternative option
included
was at risk of being developed and
relayed in the short to medium term
i'm just asking about a communication
strategy
in
announcing the results of their
deliberation are we going to emphasize
that point a little bit for the sake of
of our ratepayers
who prefer preferred the more expensive
option just so it's clear
if that's their decision
um i think to be fair we would only be
speculating
on on why that was their option and we
haven't made a decision yet
and
i can speak to that chair if you wish
yes thanks rihanna
um i think just when we analyzed the
results and looked back at the way the
consultation document was worded i do
think on reflection that that point
around why you as a council made the
decision for the preferred option wasn't
adequately communicated in the
consultation document so yes it is
an assumption
um
but it's one that we put forward to you
so that i do think it is probably a
correct assumption
and we would certainly communicate
whatever your outcome of your decision
as the reasons behind that and make sure
that we pick that up in the
communications around city street stage
too
thank you very much
thank you councillors any further
questions at this stage
councillor clark
just some clarification on when stage
two uh commences
will you help him
who wants to have a crack at that
reality
um stage two will commence next
financial year but as i'm not sure of
the exact date at this moment i would
need to ask the rating manager
um just a flowing from that um and
reflection of uh what beck's raised um
you know i support what claire was
saying i think the um
the nature of commercial businesses you
need foot traffic
and the mall will definitely generate
that
so any anything spilling out into the
mall into esk and any of the peripheral
streets
will be more attractive than they
currently are we've got our city spread
and this is going to pull it all back in
together i don't see the casualties
being an estuary i think the casual the
gaps will be further out than that as
people move in
okay
any further questions at this stage
will go through the recommendations and
uh
we'll take the first two for a start
which is receive the next steps for city
block and city streets deliberations
and note the submissions that have been
received
somebody wish to move councillor scout
councillor soper
councillor clark yeah just just to
reflect that i'm in opposition and
receiving the report of the stage
i think the report should be left on the
table the next ppp committee is about
three weeks away
we will get the investment report then
and i think we need that part of the
puzzle before we start deciding on
whether we up
the funding level for this given that um
it puts a 1.3
increase on to the rates that we've got
in our long-term plan which will
compound year after year
so i think we do it do as our ratepay as
a disservice if we're not looking at
what investments we've got which is an
option to fund this as opposed to
pushing rates up and until we get some
clarity on what's happened to the
um
to the sale price of the our farm and if
those are go and i'm only first term but
i can remember dave saying to us way
back you cannot consider each investment
or each property you have as a normal
house you don't have mortgages or debt
loading on each one individually we
actually have a pool of debt and council
about 90 million dollars which we fund
if you go beyond 90 million
rates are going to go up
if you can drop that level down and then
reinvest the money and stay within the
90 mil in parameter your rates wouldn't
go up
and so what i want to be able to
identify is when we get the investment
report is
what's happening to the
uh the money that we get from the our
farm
because we can reallocate that money
elsewhere
or if we can't we make it happen
thanks i'll note the comment
you correct we can allocate the funds
elsewhere if there are any um but at the
same time i think we need to recognize
that this isn't the only project that
we're looking to borrow on
uh and if there is
uh funding that we're able to reallocate
elsewhere then
it may be able to go on to those other
projects however uh your comment is
noted
councillor scalp thank you i can't agree
with councillor clark on this one in the
sense that we've got an overwhelming
positive response from the community and
a mandate from the community to move
forward
it's very clear
and this is our pinnacle project so
we've invested in it heavily i
understand michael from
um his thoughts in the paper that it's
the risk content is very low so i think
we need to actually show some real
leadership today
and move forward
reverend cook
oh yes mr chair i
too wish to say
that
we have been told by the public that
they are actually liking what they see
already and they want it finished um
i think we would be remiss
if we did not hear what they are saying
because i think the document did outline
that there were
you know there was a potential for
increased cost all those sorts of things
but they want it done
and
we have that good will
we have fear energy and we need to honor
it thank you councillor lush yeah um
just
as far as the briefing document goes
with them and we talk about the increase
in the
percentage and rates and stuff like that
for me it was frustrating to not know
how much
each household in the cargo was
contributing to them all do you can you
tell me how much money that was i mean
how many thousands that is per household
that they would be paying because you
say 1.5 it becomes very confusing
dade you won't have a crack at that
um
i will try him
um chair
from from the mall perspective um
diversing the city block from the actual
streetscapes um
it's very hard to actually calculate
that
on the fly um that is something i can
come back to yep
we received the paper from this meeting
at council this afternoon so we can
bring that figure back to you then well
how many how many householders how many
households are there that pay rates uh
it's roughly 25 uh 22 and a half
thousand okay
because just to comment too with the
submissions um i thought it was telling
that only three people came up
to present these submissions one of them
was the green wizard that talked about
e-bike charges one of the guys was very
very vehemently opposed to it and one
guy just wanted to talk about traffic
for te wakahuya so
i'm not so certain about the submissions
as as though they are
i think you ask if they want to more
they say yes if you say okay you have
more we're going to pay this much
every year for the next so many years i
think um if you dug deeper i'm i'm not
so sure there is such a a will for them
all and i don't think we could see that
from the submissions i read so yeah i
just like to say that
note your comment but i guess
from having said at the table for a few
years i can assure you that when people
object to things they let you know
vociferously
i know what you're saying
and and sometimes
people
choosing not to submit uh can be read
one way or another but but like i say
those who
object are more likely to
stand up and speak forward rather than
those who are
okay with it
just as an observation
but we've got to move over a second for
the first two recommendations anyway
and
i don't hear any more questions around
those so i'll put the motion all in
favor
aye against
yes i'll record against thanks note that
councillor clark carried
recommendation three the recommendation
seeks direction so i'm looking for a
motion from the table councillor sofa
thank you mr chair i'll move um
recommendation three
with the
alternative that
consider and determine the community
well-being outcomes
do not outweigh the risks identified for
further investment in city block
second nature
noted i just had to
double check on the context of how it
was worded so i moved i'm just i'm just
doing the same yep
perhaps the
do you wish to be the executive or the
positive the positive in which case
could i suggest that you just say
determine the community well-being
outcomes outweigh the risks identified
and take out all of that that would be
that would be a much simpler way of
making sure everyone understands that
councillor lewis you're comfortable with
that amendment councillor amundsen
[Music]
thanks i guess this comes back to what i
raised earlier about the risks and
the concern that i have that so far
throughout this project since it started
in 2015
most of the risks that have been
identified have been realised so right
back at the beginning of this project
we were assured that we would be
landholders only and that a developer
would come in
and finance and do the development and
that risk was realised when a developer
did not show up at our doorstep and we
have now got ourselves in the situation
where we are in partnership with the
development
um council then sought some independent
advice around how we can ensure that the
development does meet our requirements
under the community outcomes about being
outward facing about
being something that actually
revitalises the whole city and not just
creates a moor that is inward focused
and
you know sucks everybody into it again
that information was put forward to icl
to be included as part of the um
the development of the plans and um that
was a risk that was realised and and not
done
from the beginning we were told that
retailers would flock to invercargill
and take up tenancies
in this mall if it was not an earthquake
prone building
um and if we created um you know a build
it and they will come despite the fact
that we were also told that most
developers don't start
doing a development until they have
approximately 80 of the tenants signed
up yet we
went ahead
and
with them all with two tenants signed up
or kind of signed up
and now we're in this position where we
have to provide this bank funding
because of the tenancy situation
throughout this process we have been the
biggest investor in the development
from a financial point of view not just
within the mall itself but by the time
you add in all the streetscape work
around the outside as well
yet we seem to have very little
influence we have an outstanding person
who represents us on the icl board
but it seems that most of the
initiatives or things that we would like
to see as part of them all
are not are not
able to happen
and so i just guess i want to raise
again the fact that some risks have been
identified here
and are we prepared for these risks to
become a reality like all of these other
risks that we have had and are we
prepared to make more sacrifices
of other
council
projects or initiatives i mean looking
we've we've put off the water tower
because we didn't have enough money in
the long term plan
to do it we have done something
not as good as we possibly could have
with anderson house for the same reasons
and we are investing a whole lot of
money in the city streetscape which i do
hope
will help to counter some of the
you know potential
negatives that might happen
and i guess hindsight is a
wonderful thing and i sometimes think to
myself what would have happened if we
had have taken that original 25 million
dollars
that we put into this project that was
to be the extent of our investment in
this project and we have used that to
enhance our built heritage
buildings
and would that have possibly been a
braver bolder and more transformational
thing for us to have done
so whilst i'm going to vote in favor of
this because
we have
made a commitment
and
and we are on the pathway and it would
be irresponsible not to i really do
think we need to bear in mind that more
of these risks might be realized as we
go through this project and where do we
draw the line around how much more money
we invest in it and how much more things
we sacrifice
from a council point of view
of other projects that we might want to
do and i'm thinking of the museum in
particular
but you know there's lots of other
things that we could be doing to enhance
our city and to create a city with heart
so just to clarify you uh speaking in
support of the motion
i'm speaking in
support of the motion but raising
the issues around the risks because we
have identified risks and there are
many of them that have been realized
already and there's nothing to say that
the risks that have been identified here
will equally not be realized and put in
jeopardy other projects that the council
might want to be part of or other things
you know that the council might want to
do thanks i mean that's why risks are
identified one of the things that wasn't
identified in the initial risk profile
was a global pandemic
nor the very rapidly changing
geopolitical situation in the northern
hemisphere
but that said we do need to be cognizant
of the risks
questions or comments councillors
councillor lewis very briefly chair
thank you
if we had delay or delayed the initial
start off of the inner city development
i would hate to think what the
escalation and prices of building
materials would have resulted in as far
as increased costs go i think it's quite
prudent to start it certainly there are
uncertainties which have come through
but if it had been delayed with the
building materials
estimated had gone up between 20 to 40
percent then the prices would be major
and the risks would be extensive and the
cost
increases would be
so
much of an impact it probably wouldn't
have happened it would be still back in
the time warp of many years ago with
broken down buildings in the middle of
town
so i'm really pleased that we actually
made that call
dug in and did it and the development is
continuing and sure some extra costs
come up it will be always with things
like pandemics
but i think we've done the right thing
i'm very happy to support this motion
thank you councillor sopa
thanks mr chair
i suppose for me it goes back to the um
the philosophy
and the principles on which we made the
decision in the first place was that we
saw
a need to create a heart for our
community that was missing
um and the summary from
people on the street who still talk to
us about this project is that that is
the community well-being they are most
hoping to get out of this not a simple
shopping mall
but a a heart back in the city that was
missing
for me
you can
second guess almost any decision a
previous council has taken
and you can think what if we had done
this or that
the fact is we took the decision we did
to go ahead with an exciting project
that the majority of air
populace was telling us was an exciting
project they wanted because we were
looking for community outcomes that
would make a step change
for the invercargill and southland
community
i think this project still delivers that
yes there are other very important
projects
for the city including the museum that
we have to take forward um in the
the best way possible but i don't think
it takes away from the fact that this
project was always about delivering the
best for what our community said they
wanted and that's why i'm very keen that
we
make sure this does deliver everything
our community have
pretty much by the majority constantly
said they wanted and i just remind
councillors of the very fact that the
city streets upgrade alternative option
which was the more expensive option was
the one that has submitters preferred
um speaks for itself the submitters who
read the consultation document saw
that that the difference there and the
rates increase was between 1.3 with the
option council was recommended
i was recommending or 1.5
for the more expensive option that many
of them said they preferred
and the reason most of those who
preferred the more expensive option gave
was that they wanted they wanted it
finished and they wanted the best job
possible done
so for me
all the philosophical
and principled reasons for which we made
the decision in the first place to
invest in this project are still very
much there
and this is our chance
to
follow through on that um and i'm very
pleased that we have accepted the report
and are going ahead because for me
that's
to have actually hesitated to have set
this aside for a few weeks to another
meeting would have been the wrong
decision for us thank you thanks as the
original mover of the motion
uh you get the the final right of reply
so i'll close off this nothing new sorry
councillor lush yeah i am
it's caused me a great deal of
conservation this whole situation with
them all um you talk about people
if they're motivated they will make
submissions and you haven't heard much
from an outsider and i wasn't outsider
until
30 months ago before i ran for council
what was going on with council with them
all was incredibly confusing um
and you know i think we see on social
media apps how the people of indica will
communicate with stories and news
they're not diving deep they don't have
a huge amount of understanding because
most of what happens in council
appears to be stuff that is confusing or
um too esoteric or something that
they're not really interested in they
pay their rates they get on with it give
them a wall and they'll say yay
to me this has been
from the very beginning not only a bad
idea but an idea that there wasn't even
mandated by the election of other people
for me when we wandered around them all
with that open day and i saw that
farmers took up most of it there was so
very little
facing to the road with shops
i've found an incredibly heartbreaking
experience to wander around the city
where i've been for 20 years
and see it pretty much just like a giant
box to a giant farmers i know in a
week's time we're going to be
considering the museum
whose job is to preserve the tauranga
that are in the city um to preserve our
treasures but at the same time
we've demolished a whole block
so i think in
all earnesters we can't get behind a
museum about preserving our city
when we're involved in destroying our
city and when we look at the tenants
that have come reluctantly we look at
the shops we've lost zookeepers cafe one
of the country's great cafes you know
the venom hairdresser counselor kits
lolly shop we've lost all of this
for what cotton on glasses and that's it
and it just
i
i mean as a new counselor i have trouble
getting behind a project like this i'm
not quite sure which way we can go to
stop it happening
chair you talk about a global pandemic
and
travels in the northern europe i can't
understand what that's got to do with it
i would even think with the likes of
things like this we want to now
look and if there's some sort of clause
we can get out of this if there's some
sort of i know most contracts ever have
a clause that you can get yourself out
of a situation like that because i see
this when there's a there's a mentality
of let's just get it done so we go to
the election and get reelected and say
we've done this i just don't think it
stacks up i think um i think we've got
to blow this whole thing up work out
what its value is
and get ourselves out of the whole deal
because i'm in a situation where i think
if if we look at it going forward um
you know we cannot i just think we've
all got rose tinted glasses with how
well it's going to turn out none of it
seems to be turning out well from the
design to the execution to the tenancy
so
yeah that's my rant over but i have um
i just think that we've got ourselves
we continue to get ourselves involved in
commercial
deals through i don't know what it's
through through lack of leadership or
what that seemed to
produce very poor outcomes for
invercargill i've been here for 20 years
we didn't get the carcaporium going we
didn't get the invigo child friendly
thing going there's no vision we just
seem to go from bad commercial decision
to bad commercial decision and i can't
even work out when it's going to stop
and if we go on with the situation now
this time then what's going to happen
further down the track we're going to
get involved with something else because
the lessons aren't going to be learned
so
that's my take on it how that talks that
motion i'm not entirely sure i mean
either but i but i feel that
i feel that it's
that it's a voice that needs to be heard
that we just through steps we get
ourselves involved with something that's
that's
i think the opening day we go there we
get a cotton on we get sales pizza we
get a lessons
shops we've probably pretty much already
got and um
and and that's all the money from all
the rate pay has gone that's going to
prevent all the other exciting things
happening
uh for invercargill
just to note that venom are at 20
downstream uh the
geopolitical situation in the northern
hemisphere can have an impact on global
markets which affects
finance rates those were those
references councillor clark yeah just a
couple of reflections on what my
colleagues have said don't agree don't
disagree with most of it
um for your benefit marcus um
you asked what the debt loading would be
with the 70 million dollars we put into
streetscapes and the mall it's about
3100 per ratepayer
so if you've got a house and you're
paying rates on it that's what your your
share of the debt's gone up by my
calculation that's simply 70 million
divided by
as michael said 22 and a half thousand
ratepayers
um when we look at the increased
potential increase for this
streetscape which we're now discussing
it's 1.3
and and and that impact is about 80
cents per week per rate per hour so it's
not significant
and we get pretty scared on on these
1. 1.3 going up and up and i
still nervous about that because it does
compound but it's less than a dollar a
week per repair to get
the street skates
finished to the level that we've been
asked to do
council is any further questions just a
reminder that uh
when you're not speaking if you could
put your mask on thanks counselor kit
yeah thank you mr chairman
having lived and breathed that
city block for 35 years as not only a
business owner but a manager
and
a building owner
i was very nervous
five years ago
when it was mooted that
maybe council be involved in a brand new
city block
but as it nears its completion
i'm getting excited we've had hurdles
we've had a developer pull out of
21 million we've had hurdles all along
the way
it's getting to that stage where it's
almost finished
and i believe it'll do so much for our
city
not only our city but our province
also with the two new hotels and the cbd
all this
will attract thousands of visitors to
our city
and i would probably write it right up
there the
number of years i've been on council we
put a lot of effort in behind about
obtaining sit 0 fees
the stadium
the rebuild of the stadium after the
snow in 2010 the velodrome
the airport
i think will be very very proud and we
should be proud
of this build this great
great huge building the whole city block
and what it will do for our city and
people that come to visit our city as i
said earlier it'll attract thousands of
visitors so bring it on
thank you any other questions council or
comments rather since we've moved to
that part
councillor arnold
um
quite a few of the other councillors
councillor kent i think this is the most
exciting thing that's happened in
macabre in my lifetime i've been here my
entire life and i think this is a
transformational for invercargill
and i think because of what's happened
that that's one of the reasons why
you're actually
getting the second hotel
and um i just think it's um it's just uh
you know it'll be evolved as time goes
by i mean i'm fully supportive and just
want to see the thing finished and
i'm aware that
the submitters that we did have um the
majority
want the same thing they want they want
they want a good a good product and a
good outcome and it will transform into
cargo
okay
councillor
thanks mr chair as the mover of the
motion
i thought i'd made the final comment but
i just feel that one should stick by
tradition and
let the mover have the final comment
unless my seconder wants to say
something further
[Music]
i think the last two speakers have have
illustrated for me some of the
some of the actual excitement that is
there in our community for this project
and i just want to reflect as a former
comment
as some people spoke in this debate i
remembered some of the controversy of
the
eve paul library
proposal and building of many years ago
and the way in which there was
similar
adamant
um
negative feeling about that building
the council of that time bravely went
forward and built it because it was the
right thing to do it was a great
community outcome and it was very much
needed
that library has proudly sat there for
many years
being one of the great attractors in our
center city
we have now taken the decision
that we can add something equally as
exciting and fundamental as a community
wellbeing delivery
that will actually support and i believe
make that library even more used than it
currently is
and bring back even more life to that
center city and pride to that center
city and and thanks to the last two
speakers who actually mentioned the the
pride aspect
so um as i said in my earlier speech i i
think this is not the moment for any any
cold feet or any reflections on perhaps
we should um
halt the proposal or lessen the proposal
in any ways
i
remember very clearly um the principles
of democracy
we invited a consultation we got
very firmly from the members of of the
public who responded
the signal that they wished us to go
ahead
um i believe that those submitters were
well aware of this of the rates increase
that implied for for the time it did
um and that they
wanted
a project they see as exciting to go
ahead
and
i didn't think that this particular
recommendation would cause
quite this much debate
it seemed to me a simple matter of
whether community outbreak our
well-being
outcomes did um outweigh the risks and i
thought the risks were very clearly
defined
and
reasonably minor in terms of this
project so i'm very comfortable to have
moved this motion
and i do urge all councillors to to vote
for it thank you thank you councillor
sopa with that in mind i will now put
the motion which is consider and
determine the community well-being
outcomes outweigh the risks identified
for further investment in city block
those in favor please say aye aye aye
aye
carried
resolution four uh if somebody wishes to
move considering whether to increase
council's investment into city block by
up to 7.5 million to be funded through
loan funding noting there's no
anticipated impact on rates
is there a
mover for that counsellor arnold
seconded counsellor scout
that's open for discussion
bearing in mind we've all pretty much
expressed good comment through on that
uh
item three if there is none i'll put the
motion all in favor
against
carried
item five is to consider whether to
provide a 22.75 million dollar short
term loan to city block developers to be
funded through loan funding noting that
there is no anticipated impact on rates
as they remove it for that council of
scout councillor arnold
comments
yes your worship
thank you
thanks sir thank you as you say it's a
similar situation of really
stopping or going and
we have to
take notice of the submitters as well
and
every time it was raised at
different
stages
the
overwhelming
feeling or
i got was that
that the worst possible scenario
is if the job isn't finished
and i don't think we've really got a
little choice at this stage but to back
up for all we can
and make sure that it's a success
thank you sir
it's been moved and seconded
there are no further comments i'll put
the motion all in favor
against
carried
item six is determined to or not to
increase funding through the annual plan
into the city streets by 13.6 which is
the preferred option
we loan funded noting the forecast of
1.3 increase in rates council amundsen
i'm happy to move um that we do
go with the
13.6 second bit
move down second it
it's open for comment
sorry
uh reverend cook
yes i am going to declare a perception
of interest as well
as a contract
um
to deliver part of the streetscape
project so i will not be voting
versioned noted thank you for that
so with that one abstention i'll now put
the motion all in favor
all right
again all right yeah am i pleased
noting councillor clark's opposition
or vote against rather
councillor emerson
just going back to what i've already
mentioned i did wonder whether there was
any appetite for council to put a line
in the sand about
um this being the extent of our funding
for this project
[Music]
just putting it out there now's the time
i assume to do that
well if there was any
further
increase required again that would also
need to go out for consultation
okay
that brings item three to a close and
we move on to item four which is
targeted consultation
rhiannon
thank you chair um so this matter
relates to
two specific streets northwood avenue
and richfield drive and a targeted
consultation with homeowners that would
be um affected by a change in the
addressing and numbering so the reports
for information just to let you know we
will be um communicating with those um
homeowners
today um to let them know following this
meeting of this proposed plan as the
report outlines it does arise for a
change in the planning around the road
layout which has happened over the
decade of which the development's been
done and means that the current road
layout no longer makes logical sense
happy to take any question thanks
rhiannon so a really uh an informative
procedure two recommendations
somebody prepared to move counselor
scout counselor kit
questions or comments
if there are none i'll put the motion
all in favor
against
carried
uh third item is the um
paper on grants funding for the annual
plan again rhiannon
um so thank you chair yes this paper
relates to grants funding and
consideration of um funding decisions
for the next financial year
um
so you may recall that in
2020 council undertook a review of its
funds um and at that point that resulted
in the community wellbeing fund being
formed um and this paper outlines
the progress of that fund and meeting
its priorities which was around better
alignment with council's vision and
strategic goals
creating a more flexible fund that was
easier for members of the community to
understand and to apply for
so at the time of that review
there were a number of other small funds
that were overlooked so i'm putting
these forward for your consideration at
least this time so the first of those is
the urban rejuvenation fund which was a
small fund that was linked to the urban
rejuvenation committee
so there are some options there for you
to consider
um for the allocation of that funding in
the next financial year the recommended
option is to um transfer that amount of
funding to the
community wellbeing fund and for that
fund to be able to
consider
consider those applications so
essentially
urban rejuvenation projects kind of
already apply um to the community
wellbeing fund
the second
amount is around a
reallocation of a fund that was
a previous
ltp or annual plan amount and so
the strategic focus for council is
really to provide everyone with a kind
of level playing field in terms of how
we receive funding applications so the
recommendation is that that
community wellbeing fund be um increased
by the amount
of the previous funding allocation and
for the southern wall homes trust to be
able to apply to the community
well-being fund
and the third element is the emergency
grant fund
which was a fund that was previously
held within the mayoral budget
um it was there to enable council to
respond to emergency events
it is out of alignment with the revenue
and financing policy
so it's recommended to remove
that fund
funding amount from the annual plan
budget
um
so happy to take any questions
council lewis commented i'm actually
quite happy to move the first three
recommendations which will apply to
apply to this this is going to result in
standardization of applications through
ratepayers funded money it's not going
anything
it's not going to result in any extra
funds being allocated because of the
funds aren't allocated within the
financial year it rolls over and we
start again so we may actually resolve
some saving in the present time
we have
quite a few applications which to our
community will be in fund which are
being held over because the pandemic if
um if the conditions don't change
for as far as
number of participants of events
we're going to lose that money we're not
going to lose it we're just not going to
spend it so we'll be a saving to rate
those anyway
but the standardization of the extra
funds as round and as mentioned i think
will put a level level playing field for
all applicants not not specifically
targeted to other
people who have a preferential treatment
respect
is it australia or does it um
[Music]
does it accumulate it doesn't we can't
roll over the funds for the community or
being funded to the next year
we have some delays that's if an
application
for an event that doesn't uh go on
straight away we have up to 18 months to
to apply for that fund
we have funds which are
at the moment quite a few funds which
unfortunately haven't been picked up
council skill would be quite aware of
that for the situation
of covert
it's not money that's uh destined for
two years down the track
but there is a slight delay should the
event be out to be held
so it could result in a saving in some
respect we hope not because it would
mean the events aren't being carried out
for the benefit of our rate payers
so i'll come to councillor in just a
moment but you were moving i would like
to move the first three recommendations
first three
yeah that one doesn't apply to the
community will be intended you could
still move it yep
sorry there was that a yes or no no i'm
just i would like to move the first
three three okay is there
did you have something to add
no no i was just listening to what
graham said agree concur thank you
councillor
thanks mr chair um
i just want to remind council that i am
the appointee on the southern warm homes
trust now there is an appointment that
is made technically by eil but it is
included in council's appointment
registers
that means that i should not vote on
recommendation three i'm very
comfortable to vote on the others but i
just do want to point out that i think
it would be wise for me not to vote on
recommendation three
and if the
movers didn't mind adjusting their um
move to accommodation
might be helpful yep so
i'm quite happy to change it to taking
it one by one through the through the
three
councillor abbott you're comfortable
with that
one by one
thank you let's do that then
recommendation one receive the report
grants funding annual plan that's been
moved to council lower secretary
councillor abbott questions or comments
i'll put the motion all in favor all
right against
carrie thank you item two agree to
reallocate 15 000 in funding from the
urban rejuvenation fund to the community
wellbeing fund moved councillor lewis
seconded councillor abbott open for
comment
there is none to put the motion all in
favor aye aye against
carrie thank you for that uh
recommendation three agree to increase
the community well-being fund by fifty
thousand dollars again moved councillor
lewis seconded councillor abbott noting
the abstention of councillor sopa
questions or comments
so just your arms standing up there
councillor arnold or rick thank you
so there are none i'll put the motion
all in favor
all right against
carrie that brings us to recommendation
for looking for remover or not somebody
prepared to move the
100 000 allocated for emergency grants
be removed councillor clark yeah i'll
move there
secondary councillor amundsen open for
comment
yes council are your worship the um
when we had the first lot of flooding um
the
the um
of a hundred thousand
i believe to
uh southland district and
gore
district council
is that um
would that be able to be used for a
situation like that again what we had to
do was pass a resolution
at council
uh you worship if there were an
emergency that arose that felt the
council felt the need it wanted to
contribute to emotion could come to the
table at any stage
any other questions or comments just
that means
counselor rabbit sorry
just a question so it's really just a
digitally fund
i don't think it's been drawn on and
that's right just sits there so it's
there
correct
counselor clark
and that's the issue he just sits there
and it could be used elsewhere i think
it has been drawn on once from my memory
for a particular case matera i think we
drew a small amount claire might really
help with that but either way why would
we lock in funds when we can be using
them elsewhere and just consider on a
case by case basis
mr chair the um donation that was given
to the flooding that occurred in
february 2022
in fact was not required because
there was not as many there were not as
many calls as had been anticipated if
there was an event then
you would be able to resolve to
contribute as you saw fit but it's
it's officer advice that it's
inappropriate to be rating today's rate
payers for an event that might not occur
uh and it's not that you are actually
developing a a battle fund so to speak
it becomes part of the surplus at the
year end so
it would be more appropriate to cease
the practice
february 2020
councillor lewis thank you very much
chair
just reading the option remove the
hundred thousand from the annual budget
and address requests for emergency funds
which arise on a case-by-case basis so
it's still available it's to apply case
by case basis but it's not rated for
which is a saving
thank you
thank you
there's no further questions or comments
i'll put the motion all in favor
aye against
carrie
councillors there are no further items
in general business uh therefore we will
be moving to discuss the items in public
excluded
which includes the great south draft
statement of intent
the reasons listed in the agenda under
72v2
of the lda
there is also a
monolate item on the
city block funding which is informative
rather than seeking a decision
so with that edition i'll move that we
go into public excluded councillor clark
just before we moved in with your
blessing um one of the issues i i still
struggle with a little bit and this was
raised beginning the term in 2019
was when we go into a public excluded
how long do the minutes of those
meetings stay public so now some would
should stay there forever because
they're commercially sensitive they
might be staff related
but we don't seem to have developed even
though we said we were going to a
process where we would review what's in
pe and what can subsequently be released
and we at the time we kicked around
issues like
um
as we discussed something in pe we could
say yep this this needs to stay there
for three months six months a year
forever or we could do an annual review
all the staff could do an annual review
somebody could because it just seems to
me it just gets lost in the system and
it never comes to light
and and sometimes the reasons for it
being
in public excluded is only a short-term
thing while we consider
issues or it might be commercially
sensitive that aren't a year or two
later so just wanted the flag that
um
we always get criticism that we take too
much into pe or we seem to um and so the
defense that is well we need to have an
mpe but we will release when it's
appropriate but we just don't get to
that stage though so i'll go to mrs
hadley in just a moment
but preempt that with
a great deal
less
is held in public excluded these days
than than used to be in the past
this council and previous councils have
challenged
what goes into public excluded
and i have chaired meetings where there
was a recommendation to go into public
excluded the council has presented
information that challenged that and
i've agreed that they've been correct
and we've ended up taking them in
in public so that system for challenging
um what we discuss and pe is more
vigorous now than it used to be
in some circumstances you're quite right
the information does need to remain
out of the
the public eye because of commercial
sensitivity in some instances
a statement is able to be issued after
the meeting
but claire do you wish to
further mr chair i would just draw a
councillor's attention to the reports
in public excluded that set out in the
table at the start the section of the
act the plain english reason and when
the report can be released
now we are working
more harder
to get more of a practice around
proactively released reports
and we are looking at including such a
section on the website
like many things it's not something
that's resolved overnight but
in the words of the ads it will happen
comfortable with that counsellor
yeah thank you
thanks for that
uh so back to the motion for going into
public excluded i'll put that all in
favor
aye
against
carrie will go into public excluded and